John what's your take on netflix
releasing house of cards all in one day
how they ended the same with arrested
development I think there's a benefit to
it which is it allows some of the
viewers that binge viewing experience
and to see how the sequencing of the
episodes is going to work and by the way
keep in mind the audience for cereals is
different for the other than the
audience for the standalone show a big
part of the pleasure for the cereal
audience is to see this complex weave
and the connection between all the
episodes as they've built now that's
very different from a standalone
audience the standalone audience loves
to have that single increment of story
set up and solve right and date that
means they don't have to watch every
week maybe I missed a couple of weeks I
don't have to worry that when I come
back to the show all these things have
happened that I'm going to be hopelessly
behind right so these the cereal story
form is geared for religious viewing and
religious viewers people who you know
they just love lost and their fanatic
about loss but if but those people who
didn't get in on lost right at the
beginning they throw up to and say you
know how can I possibly figure this
thing out I'm lost on loss so you know
they don't even try but so the benefit
of releasing it these these shows all at
once is that you get that religious
viewer but there's a real cost to it
which is it becomes less of an event
every week you know as we're shooting
this right now the new season of mad men
has just begun and for religious viewers
of madmen that moment Sunday night when
the
new mad men episode happens is a
galvanizing moment it is a creates a
community of people who appreciate that
show and you know that the anticipation
of it is tremendous if they had released
all the madmen episodes for this coming
season you wouldn't get that and I think
that's that's a big loss
you